dr anthony fauci is director of the
national institute of allergy and
infectious diseases
he's also a member of president trump's
coronavirus task force
good morning to you dr fauci it's very
good to see you we've just done a piece
where
good morning gail good to be with you
i'm so glad you're here listen we all
know the cases are
climbing things are getting out of
control and people are very afraid why
is this happening
again right now you predicted it though
earlier
you know so unfortunately i did gail
there are a number of factors that are
feeding into this
you know our baseline of infections all
along
has never gone down to a level that
would allow you to be
easily controllable when you get cases
that soar up for a variety of reasons
right now as we are in the cool season
of the fall
and soon to enter the cold season of the
winter that makes it
very problematic because people out of
necessity
will be congregating indoors more than
outdoors this is a particular
issue as we're approaching the holiday
season
of thanksgiving i've heard you say the
calvary is coming
but it doesn't mean you put down your
weapons and that people are letting
that is absolutely correct people are
letting their guards down
you know it's it's understandable i
don't want to be critical of that but we
want to just plead with them to
understand
the dynamics of this outbreak if you do
that we'll continue to soar
if we do the things that are simple
public health measures
that soaring will level and start to
come down
you add that to the help of a vaccine
we can turn this around it is not futile
dr judge judges told us david bagno that
the testing that we need in this country
is far below what it needs to be
do you agree with that and what does
that mean exactly
yeah well i think with what dr john was
saying is what many of us have been
saying
is that there is community spread right
now which means there are people in
society
who are infecting others they don't have
symptoms they don't know they're
infected
the only way you can get at them is if
you only test
people who are symptomatic you are going
to miss
the sim the asymptomatic people who are
silently spreading the outbreak
so we need to pour more testing into the
community
to get a feel and identify who in the
community
is spreading the infection because it
isn't only
a symptomatic person i want to talk to
you briefly about thanksgiving i'm
changing my plans after listening to you
you're saying you're not even going to
spend thanksgiving with your
with your lovely daughters you're
keeping your thanksgiving celebration
very small
if you're with a small group of people
do you need to wear a mask indoors
somebody told me that even if you're in
your house
you have to wear a mask is that true
you know yes it is true now obviously
it's kind of difficult
to be eating and drinking at a dinner
with a mask on you can't do that
but to the extent that you can keep that
mask on i mean
nothing is going to be perfect in this
but if you're indoors and gathering with
people
even if it's a relatively small group to
the extent possible
keep the mask on even if you are indoors
now obviously even if we've all tested
negative dr fauci
well well that's a different thing i
mean then the risk goes way down and
then you make a risk assessment
you know we always talk about things
nothing is risk-free
but when you do a risk-benefit ratio and
you say to yourself
now wait a minute i just got tested my
husband or wife just got tested our
children are coming in
they just got tested of course it's not
a hundred percent that they could have
gotten infected
from the time they got tested to the
time they got there
but when you get that degree of
minimization of risk
then you really use some common sense
and say you know i'm willing to take
that very very small risk so i don't
have to be walking around the house with
a mask
people who say wearing a mask indoors
they're really talking about when you
get into a setting
where you're really unsure what the
status of people
are but when families go the extra mile
of either quarantining or getting tested
then i don't think you really have to
say every moment you're in the house you
have to have a risk you've got to use
some common sense and make sure you look
at what relative risks are
because the relative risk is going to go
way down if everyone's been tested
or people have been quarantined so it's
just really common sense
in that regard and before you go i want
to know how you're doing listen you get
death threats you work
24 7. you know there are issues with the
white house i'm wondering how you're
holding up to all of this i know it's
your job
i get it but i want to know how you're
holding up physically and mentally
well well thank you for asking i'm
actually doing fine and the reason i'm
doing fine is twofold i have
i've taught myself over the years to
focus like a laser on what my goal is
and what
what i need to do and to me that's a big
thing it's the health of safety and the
welfare
of the american people that driving
force makes all that other stuff
that you're talking about become
peripheral noise that i don't pay
attention to
and the other thing i have a spectacular
wife who is amazingly supportive of me
and has been
now for the last 36 or plus years so
i'm doing fine but thank you for asking
all right we thank you dr
fauci thank you for taking the time
thank you